you
and you can see that when a raspberry
stated the vigor of these plants and the
productivity at this point when we were
doing some insecticide efficacy studies
we had greater than five raspberry on
board while B per plant and this is what
the plants looked like biology and
identification this is a clear win moth
it's native to areas from New England to
Georgia in western Nebraska and South to
Louisiana has been reported damaging
plants in British Columbia and
California and even in New Mexico
identification you can see the adults
have these yellow bands makes him look
like a yellow jacket and the the young
the larvae are in the in the cane or in
the crown and they're just a typical
white seceded a clearing moth hosts
typically in our in Arkansas we see a
mostly a damaging blackberry but they
are reported to get on do billion
raspberry for the North symptoms
tumbling in the crown sometime in May
and June you start seeing them tunneling
into the lower part of the cane and here
you can actually see inside there inside
that tunnel the head of the larvae
chains are griddled at the base and they
wilt as you can see it to the right here
it kind of it looks like a shepherd's
crook and they're dead all the weight of
the soil line and this type of thing
happens in June July and August and as I
mentioned in the previous slide yields
do drop considerably and the plants will
eventually die if they get enough larval
damaged biology eggs are laid on the
other side of the leaf the lava rocks
down the King to just below the soil
line and then tunnels into the side of
the chain word over winters this is a
photo from Washington State
then in the spring started and really
April in our area and probably may
likely May for the north the lava tiles
and the in the crowns and you can see in
the south we have 11 month a life cycle
where it finishes in one full year and
in the north it actually takes a full
two years as a larva 22 months
sometime in the fall I think in the
further north you start seeing these
people skins coming out in late August
early September in our area it comes out
more like in mid September and you can
find adults throughout most of September
or October and here's a there's a male
and a female there's a mating pair and
then today you can find females in this
posture where you can actually see them
curling their abdomen under the leaf and
lay in an egg starving there's two ways
of scouting
I am July if you're just looking for
damage you can actually look for the
dying canes and in trellis plantings a
lot of times the Canes don't get to move
very much with the rend and they don't
break off at the bottom so you don't see
the dying chain but later in the season
you can also cut and look for the larvae
in the hole in the tunnel in September
or late August you can look for females
laying eggs well you can actually look
for eggs now in terms of control we have
been working on some biological control
and we've also been testing various
other insecticides ice will control if
the population isn't too high you can
actually find which plants are infested
in July before they pupate and
move the plant we have been having
slight success using biological control
and this is something that we find that
sometime at bud break in spring we can
irrigate and soil drench the plants with
some Lima totes but the best we've done
so far is about 53 percent reduction in
laurel count this is research done by
lies
student Jackie McKern we have done both
releases of nematodes s fell TI h
bacteria for and s couple cap C you can
see the rate and the dates late October
this is after egg hatch no this is
really about the time when the larva in
our area have started moving up into the
McCain again we tried a second year in
November with applications and then the
following you did it right at bud swell
trying to make sure we got the larvae
here you can see the results of correct
kind applications we can get anywhere
from 80 to 100 percent control Brigade
Zion is now canceled it used to be our
standard compound as a soil drench but
Brigade which is bifenthrin works real
well and that's the only thing
registered right now some of our growers
did not like the label it says user use
200 gallons per acre of this material so
we tried 50 100 and 200 gallon rates as
a soil drench
and you can see we had similar fairly
similar control with all rates from 50
to 200 gallons but right now the label
says 200 you can see in May when the
live we have already tunneled into the
crown they're pretty much unexposed to
pesticide and they also it's very
difficult for nematodes seem very human
toads controlling the larvae at that
time compared to an earlier application
just when they're starting to feed on
their on the Canes
so we do have some success with bio
control but not a whole lot now applying
your soil drench whether it be nematodes
or insecticide you have to keep a
weed-free strip so the material gets
down to the crown weeds cause poor
coverage and you can see our tractor
driver trying to apply this material to
the base of the plants but he has to go
through all that grass and in this case
he's applying that egg catch which is in
October in our area or even as late as
early November and you can actually
delay until bud break in the spring
which is April and I are which may be
may in years and like I said the gate is
only been registered
okay I'm I've moved my speaker a little
bit away from my mouth is that a little
better okay presume data you can see you
can see this map in the green by all the
locations where they've been reported
feeding on ripening fruit so if you're
outside that area you can ignore the
next few minutes but it's an interesting
insect identification the adults have
these memos fluorescent green wings
they're from one to one-and-a-half
inches long the lava is a grub it's C
shaped and has a vertical raster you can
see that right here these hairs are in a
two rows vertically these are the hosts
they attack ripening fruit you see
grapes APIs and you can get them on
blackberries typically most of our
blackberries are almost finishing by the
time the adults come out here you can
see the adults coming out in mostly in
July and August there's a lot of it's
easy to recognize it's usually nocturnal
that it and eyes along on its back in
the grassy areas to pates in the soil in
a soil cell you get some adults coming
out in late June early July they lay
eggs they get hungry go feed on fruit
anything ripe the larvae feed on
decomposed organic matter so if you have
a pasture
with organic matter when they were
that's where they'll be
we do have a really method for our
various studies we just use soil with a
some alfalfa meal as a nutrient source
in May we can actually sift the soil we
get the pupil cells get some of the
larvae there's a soil salt right there
and we can sex the beetles the adults
can looks like two cats eyes on the
female and this more horizontal
structure on the on the male in terms of
their abdomen tip we've been developing
a trap for last trap in green gene Venus
and you can see the the box on the upper
left we have we catch thousands of these
beetles so they had to increase the trap
capture size we're bringing beetle ear
that's actually available like from
Great Lakes IPM which we developed and
also we use 91% isopropanol and you can
see that both of those they're fairly
similar counts ten thousand fourteen
thousand this is a week count in one
week's time we catch that many green
beetle control there's a number of
compounds registered for green gene
beetles but most of them have more than
a three-day pre-harvest interval and
what you're trying to do is get them off
ripening fruit so it's kind of a tricky
deal to find the right compound mass
trapping so far has not been effective
after our first year but we think that
using several traps around the planning
we may after several years be able to
mass trap the population out of the area
so they'll be below damaging levels
I know Japanese bill is in your area you
can see this is the distribution map
anything in purple so basically anything
from Iowa Minnesota Iowa Missouri
Arkansas and Georgia North totally into
Vermont and in Maine just for your
information I'm located in this hot spot
right here Northwest Arkansas Japanese
byd fairly easy to identify it's about
half the size of a green Jindal has
brown wings has these six white spots on
the side of the abdomen with this nice
couple of Tufts on the tip since it
shaped larvae and a V regester
that's this kind of v-shaped Ames right
here
Japanese deals amenities pests from
Japan 300 species of plants that it
feeds on and mostly it's a defoliator
but you can see on the crepe or the crab
apple in the middle it will feed on
fruit and it does get on blackberries
but we see more damage on the leaves and
and the flowers recently Maxie and
Pfeiffer produced this nice graph
showing the number of Japanese beetles
per 2 meters a row relative to several
varieties of raspberry and you can see
that the first four are very low in
terms of Japanese beetle counts but then
you get autumn bliss fall Grove and
praline seem to be a little bit more
susceptible Japanese beetles different
affiliation of those same rasberry
varieties here you can see percent
defoliation and again fouled veiled
autumn glyphs and pale would seem to
have the most foliar damage but even 5%
doesn't seem to be a whole lot but in
our area it tends to be more the leaves
around the flowers so that could be
damaging scouting in control Japanese
beetles come out in June in our area
July up in Michigan and you can see they
like to feed on things on the top part
of plants there's a this is grapes they
just skeletonized the top part of the
plant and our growth ever since they've
been here since about 2002 we've been it
haven't apply weekly insecticides to
prevent that defoliation this year we
tried using surround kale and clay on
the plants and you can see the
difference in the foliation we
drastically
the affiliation with the surround but
ever after the rainfall we've had to
reapply that to maintain that
whitewashed look so that does seem to be
a good alternative to several weekly
sprays of insecticide okay our last the
best insect all organism all talked
about is a broad bite this is a new pest
in our area it's usually a problem in
greenhouse plants and temperate and
subtropical regions as you can see it
gets on pepper and impatience and causes
leaf deformation but in 2007 we actually
found this on Palma came there in
blackberry on art 46 and I'll address
the Japanese beetle traps here in a
second I saw that come up on a far right
you can see on the king blackberry being
damaged here's the broad light
distribution with all the little black
dots these are the two new locations in
Arkansas in North Carolina we've found
them in both locations I don't know what
it is about Primark 46 but it seems to
the broad light seems to like that
cultivar that does it look like you can
see it's about it
tenth of a millimeter in size they're
not very big the males are yellow have
longer legs the female is more white and
it kind of you can almost see the egg
inside the female and then the egg is
clear with those 30 29 to 37 white Tufts
very characteristic where is it do AC e
pictures are infested plants compared to
the healthy plants PDF you can see it
greatly reduces cluster size and leaf
size and it curls the leaves management
we're just starting to learn how to
manage these that we did use some
predatory mites will be purchased and
released predatory mites and Java touch
has also indicated that he news
neosaurus californica s-- and got the
fairly good control on pepper there are
my decides of course that are labeled
that you can find broad light on the
label and some of the insecticidal soaps
and and oils these are many of the
publications that i mentioned during the
presentation and just to not acknowledge
some of our funding sources in organic
or integrated organic program our four
minor news program we also have some
funding from our small food consortium
at this point i'll try to answer any
questions i guess i can go back and
answer that question about Japanese
beetle traps you know if his Japanese
beetle traps around a grape vineyard we
had like 17 traps we could only trap on
one side because there was cows that
were eating our traps on the other sides
and trapped over a million Japanese
beetles and there was still the growers
still applied through sprays and his
vineyard was still losing foliage so in
a very high population Japanese beetle
traps will not mass trap and remove
enough to prevent having to use
insecticide
any other comments or questions for dr.
Johnson I think people are typing and
maybe oops
there's another one that with the same
cultural controls for crown bore work
with Cain war yeah I think Hannah will
probably mention that she'll be talking
about redneck chain bore and one of the
controls is if you have about less than
five to ten percent of your Cain's
guards you can remove those during the
pruning period but if it gets above ten
percent you're starting to cut into your
yield by quite a bit so that's kind of
where we do it cut off showing the big
differences in crown board damage and
whether that was the age of the planting
or the cultivar that provided that
difference
well duh the cultivar in the back and
that second very second side was very
new that was about two years old then
the cultivar in the front
nothing was slide - I don't know where
it's at
really it's slide for that one these are
two year olds these are about seven or
eight year old
Navajo loser I think was Apache Arapaho
it's basically makes the the leaves
white and it also creates a kind of a
dust on the on the plant so I think when
the Japanese beetles don't see the plant
as a little plant they see it as a white
structure so it's kind of camouflaged
and - I think they're really they spend
more time cleaning their mouthparts and
their legs when they're on those leaves
so it's kind of a disturbing dirty
appearance on their food it's it'd be
kind of like us putting sand in our in
our food and trying to eat that it's not
very appetizing
it's all sprayed on and it's one of
those things you have to be patient with
because it kind of goes on slow you
spray at once I had a commercial grower
uses air blast sprayer he went down the
road once and looked at and he said
what's not quite right enough so it went
again and it took about two or three
trips to get get it to a king delight -
a kind of a whitewashed appearance
- oh yeah we are seven you have to have
an agitator system in your tank
oh she doing it by backpack you do a lot
of dancing a lot of dancing and I think
that probably in the lower southern tier
they may have seen them and perhaps
certain areas of and I just want to ask
a question quickly before you move on
but the broad might that you're talking
about is at the X is it the same broad
night that's a green house past is that
what you said earlier okay yeah right
thank you very much does anyone else
have any questions or comments for dr.
Johnson he will be here through the next
presentation so perhaps at the end and I
think I'll turn mine off
this is I'd like to introduce dr. Hannah
Barak
she is from North Carolina State
University and as the an assistant
professor and extension specialist there
she actually has some responsibilities
with small fruits as well as tobacco
working to enhance pest management in
both of these crops she's interested in
landscape scale management issues host
preference behavior of insects and
invasive species biology so I'm very
happy to have dr. Brock join us to talk
about more Cain berry insect management
you
are you able to turn on your
you
sorry Han Oh
hear me alright now I have a little Mike
icon can you okay excellent
excellent alright so I'm gonna go ahead
and get started here I have just one
quick comment about Japanese beetle
traps and surround first of all done I'm
incredibly impressed that you apply
surround with a backpack my experience
with that has always been the rates of
the material you have to use make it a
pretty heavy duty amount of clay that's
going on there and I actually worked on
it in olives in California and to get
good coverage on tree crops is
particularly challenging you need a lot
of water and a lot of clay so it's a
pretty heavy duty process and then just
to comment briefly on Japanese beetle
traps we actually discourage growers
from using them in North Carolina
because the lures are incredibly
attractive they'll draw beetles in from
a great distance
but they don't actually as Don said trap
them out of the area they've been shown
to pull beetles in from as far away as
up to a mile so basically you're putting
out a little signal that you've got
something interesting and they should
come check out and along the way they
might find your planting in addition to
the trap itself so we we don't recommend
the use for the the use of them by
growers because typically they tend to
either not help with the problem or
potentially make it worse and I'm gonna
focus on another set of cane berry pest
particularly some beetles might talk a
little about thrips work that we're
doing and I'll talk briefly about some
potential paths Laura mentioned that I
have an interest in invasive species
biology so that'll come out a little bit
at the end of this talk as well but
first I want to acknowledge some folks
who have done the bulk of the cane berry
work before I arrived in the southeast
you've heard from Don this afternoon and
Don presented some work that's been done
by Doug Pfeiffer and his graduate
student Laura maxi I'll also have some
information of theirs in this talk as
well and I also want to highlight one of
my horticultural counterparts down here
at NC State Gina Fernandez she is became
very horticultural list as well as a
breeder looking particularly at
developing some heat tolerant
raspberries because those of yellow
north of us get to grow all sorts
great raspberries but we're stuck in the
southeast with the inability to grow
raspberries in the warmer parts of the
state here I also wanted to highlight a
couple internet resources Laura
mentioned my blog and feel free to check
that out I post about two to three times
a week and I try to keep that fairly
up-to-date if there's any comments that
you have on that feel free to post them
there or get in touch with me if there's
something you'd like to learn more about
and then my personal website is here
we're in the process of developing
integrated pest management web pages as
a part of this website so that's in
process as well
I want to talk a little bit about my
philosophy of integrated pest management
Before we jump in here primarily because
I'll be talking about IPM in the context
of this presentation and I want to make
sure we're all on the same page first so
when I think of IPM I think of the three
M's and for me that's minimized monitor
and manage and practically what that
means is we minimize the likelihood of
having a pest problem in our planting by
reducing the things or changing the
things we can to result in the least
hospitable environment for pests as
possible
secondly we monitor our pest populations
which means we track both on an
individual point in time and through
time to see what our pest populations
are doing also under here are some
things that Don touched on really well
specifically we need to know what
insects we have so those ID techniques
are really important and that falls
under monitoring and finally manage and
this is the thing we tend to think about
first when it comes to integrated pest
management but really it's a logical
outflow of these first two minimizing
and monitoring then we decide whether or
not we have a pest problem that requires
management
so the ways we manage pests are
threefold and again I have these lists
of kind of in terms of hierarchy first
off we start off with cultural control
those are the things we do in that
minimize category we select the right
variety we fertilize in the way that's
appropriate for pest management we prune
in ways that reduce our pest population
I'll talk about how some of those tools
apply to specific Cain Berry past as we
can further in here biocontrol is the
second tier I like to exploit so first
we do everything culturally we can to
make the least hospitable place for
pests secondly we move in and see if
there's cultural control techniques that
are appropriate
that are appropriate for the pests that
we're trying to target and again these
are things like using predators or as
Don mentioned using nematodes those are
different biological control organisms
that we can utilize in the cane berry
system and then third I like to consider
chemical control after we've considered
the first two and I break down organic
versus conventional because I think a
lot of folks particularly people who
aren't producers get organic kind of
thrown all up in there and really
organic producers still to a certain
extent may use chemical controls though
just Omri acceptable chemical controls
so as long as we're talking about
chemicals let me first mention I'm not
gonna be talking about a lot of
pesticides in this talk and that's
primarily because all of you all are
from different parts of the country
so both pest status and biology are
going to differ based on where we are
where there are differences between
people in the Northeast and the
southeast
I'll point out because I think that's
where most of our folks are from and in
general the insect pest covered in this
talk are east of the Mississippi so I'll
point out any critters that might differ
along those lines but there's as Don
showed in some of the maps that he
Illustrated with most of the organisms
that were going to talk about our king
Barry pests East and the Mississippi
so biological and cultural control
methods can generally be
generalized over lots of different
places using predatory mites using
nematodes pruning those are things we
can do pretty much anywhere but the time
at which you do those might change so
bear that in mind when I talk about
those methods chemical control options
specifically pesticides are not
generalizable registrations for
materials differ between states so I may
slip and mention some specific
pesticides at points in this talk but
contact your local Cooperative Extension
folks for local recommendations about
which materials are registered and
recommended for the pests in your area
because the label is the law that's the
most important thing to follow whenever
you're using a pesticide if it's not
labeled for the use that you're using it
for you cannot be using it so this is a
time line for the southeast for some of
the cane berry pests that Don mentioned
and that I'll be mentioning I have the
months down here along the bottom but I
also broke out the plant phenological
timings along with that so for those of
you who are not in the southeast refer
to the bloom fruit development and
harvest timings as for when these
organisms are going to be showing up
I'll be talking a little bit about
clippers let me hop ahead to the next
slide here I'll be talking a little bit
about clippers about cane bores about
stink bugs
thrips and - spotted spider mites so
let's jump right into those so rarity
costs already had a question about cane
bores we've got two different cane bores
in this system the first one that I'm
going to talk about is the raspberry
cane borer it's a longhorn beetle you
can see where it gets its name from it
has these lawn and Tennie
and it's actually in the same genus as
the raspberry stem borer so this is a
genus that is an issue on other small
fruits as well so the adults for this
particular insect appear in June the
eggs hatch in July and the larvae
overwinter in the Canes when the eggs
are laid there's a girdling that's about
a half inch apart about four to six
inches below the growth
points on a cane this will result in
some pretty distinctive tip wilting
above these two girdle points the larvas
then going to move down the cane as it
feeds toward the ground and that entire
cane will die
most of the biology studies for this
particular pasture from the north and
they suggested there's a two-year life
cycle Don mentioned that there's a
two-year life cycle for the raspberry
crumb borer in the north and a one-year
life cycle for it in the South we lack a
lot of studies on this particular
species in the South so it may be a
similar situation that we have a shorter
life cycle here I mentioned the larvae
moved down the cane as they develop
we'll talk about some cultural control
methods for cane bores in general but
for raspberry cane bore it's
particularly important to prune below
the damaged keep going on down that cane
until you no longer see tunneling in
there when you're removing them because
if you don't you might not be removing
the insect and it will continue to
develop the other cane borer that we
have and these are some slides that Don
graciously provided for me to use as
well is the redneck came board and this
is what we call a metallic wood boring
beetle they don't have those lawn and
Tennie on them and these are native to
Canada and New England out west
Minnesota and south to the Gulf states
so again an east of the Mississippi past
this is what they look like you can see
their antennae are much shorter than the
raspberry cane board
so the adults feed and mate on the
leaves and they lay their eggs only in
the prime Akane's
in the early summer the lobby then
girdle the cane you can see a feeding
cell for the larva right here with some
frass in there the skirt Alain produced
gaul produces galls in mid-summer the
larvae overwinter in the pith of the
cane these galls actually will
predispose these canes to greater
degrees of winter injury because you'll
see some photos in the next set of
slides that actually show the Canes are
kind of bunched out so they become more
susceptible to damage there's some
historic work all the way back in the
30s it actually listed some cultivars is
perhaps having some resistance to
redneck cane boy of course these are
cultivars that we're not really growing
much anymore so not a lot about our
currently grown cultivars is no but
appears that at least there's some
resistance out there in the germplasm to
this particular pest there's really no
known biological control for either of
our cane boring needles in in this
particular system our cultural control
method is very similar to the code of
the cultural control method for
raspberry kronborg during the winter as
Don mentioned if fewer than 5% of the
canes are called prude off those gold
canes and destroy them it's very
important that you don't just pile up
those canes on the side of the planting
and let them sit there because the
insects will continue to develop in them
and can emerge out as adults and
reinvest the planting so they need to be
burned chipped removed off site you can
also cut off prime Akane's down to the
soil surface and that reduces that
galling pretty distinctively and Don has
some photos from his trial that was done
in Arkansas and this is I mentioned what
that galling looks like and you can see
how it distends the cane there and can
result in some greater potential damage
so the logic for this trial was to avoid
galls on prima canes after the AG lane
was occurring in early spring
and pruning was done at several
different dates and this photo was taken
about in the middle of this and you can
see the three different plots that were
pruned out there and the gaunt number of
Gauls were then tracked and the
take-home message there is that after
that egg-laying period was when the
lowest degree of Gauls were observed and
you can we can talk with Donn a little
bit more about any additional questions
you have about this particular trial
work out I'm glad that he's sticking
around for the rest of the session so as
we mentioned cultural control if you
have less than 5% injury if there's
greater than that degree of injury and
five to ten percent is perhaps a rule of
thumb that is a rule of thumb that we
use a bit more in North Carolina if
there's greater injury there's less
someone also some pesticide options that
are available that would be used during
that egg-laying time when the adults are
out and about the target insect for
treatment is the adults we're not
targeting the larvae in this case
because they are going to be feeding
inside of the cane and difficult to get
a contact with an insecticide so spray
where the adults are the lower part of
the canes especially in the prime McCain
since that's where they're going to be
laying their eggs there are also there's
a label for systemic insecticides use
pre bloom that type of treatment would
be targeting the larvae in the cane and
not the adults moving on to Strawberry
clipper this is a weevil it's in the
same genus as the boll weevil so those
of you who might be more familiar with
that it's in the same group the adult is
a small weevil this is the type of
injury that's attributable to strawberry
Clippers they do exactly what their name
suggests they clip right below the bud
what that is is then laying an egg at
that point and the larvae will then feed
on the tip of that bud so the threshold
or the number of buds to sample is
sampling 100 clusters beginning after
first bloom these are thresholds that
were developed
Arkansas and then when damage is
observed begin insecticide treatments
but I want to caution all of you be very
very careful with bluem insecticide
treatments and this is just a link to
one of the North Carolina a chem manual
sections on insecticides that have
varying degrees of bee toxicity so this
is the sort of thing to keep an eye out
for if you run into an issue where you
expect to be treating during bloom for
whatever type of insect we try to avoid
recommending bloom treatments unless
they're absolutely necessary and I'll be
interested to see what people say in
response to Laura's question down there
in the chat Oh as to whether or not
anyone's seen damage in New York
moving on to spider mites because we
primarily grow blackberries in North
Carolina they're usually a secondary
pest for us we see them in the
all on prime McCain leaves however there
are much more serious pests in
raspberries and I will show you I'll
show you some photos that illustrate
that from the Pacific Northwest and
that's where the most work has been done
on spider mites and cane berries so
these are images of two spotted spider
mites tetra nikka sirtaki is the
scientific name and this is an adult
female you can tell that it's a female
by her rounded abdomen versus the male
here who has a pointed abdomen these are
some eggs they're perfectly spherical
they almost look like little perfectly
round grains of sand these can be pretty
easily observed with a handheld hand
lens 10x or greater would be my
recommendation these are images from the
UC IPM web page it's just WWC or IPM UC
Davis edu and I'll type that down in the
box
you
one of the challenging things with using
the Internet as your IPM tool is that
there's going to be things that are
different from region to region and the
IPM website at UC Davis is an excellent
resource for images
I wouldn't necessarily use it as a
source for pest management because as a
west of the Mississippi source it's
going to have some very different
recommendations than we would have
spider mites diapause in the winter
would and a die opposing spider mite
looks like this they're kind of salmony
orange color and these food spots will
go away as they're diapause it because
die pause means they're not eating and
they're not reproducing spider mites can
be flared by the use of broad-spectrum
insecticides and cane berries this is
where we tend to see most of a problem
in the southeast as if people are using
broad-spectrum insecticides they can
create a spider mite problem where there
may not have been one before there are
very good mite specific control options
that should be used instead of
broad-spectrum insecticides
there's no developed threshold or
scouting program for mites and cane
berries but a suggested scouting plan
for those of you that might be concerned
about them would be to sample at least
10 leaflets per acre count the number of
mites present and treat when there are
visual leaf symptoms and this is what I
mentioned about raspberries being far
more susceptible to spider mites than
blackberries will these are this is a
non infested leaf this is an infested
leaf in raspberries and I apologize for
the pitcher quality here but these are
plants that have been essentially D
foliated by spider mite feeding and I
mentioned that they're primarily there
have been primarily worked upon in the
Pacific Northwest in addition to the two
spotted spider mite which is shown here
they also have two other spider mites
that they've recorded from cane berries
the yellow spider mite and the mcdonald
spider mite so those are also out there
they're gonna differ a little bit in
appearance but their management and
feeding behavior will be essentially the
same
when we talk about those two of those
three ends of IPM minimizing and
managing the most important thing to do
for spider mites is to select the right
pesticide when mites are present
particularly in blackberries because
they don't appear to be as much of a
concern from the defoliation standpoint
as they are in raspberries so select a
material that's not going to flare
spider mites minimizing road dust can
also contribute to reducing spider mite
populations because they had out on the
undersides of leaves dust can adhere to
the webbing that they create hence their
name spider mites and create these
refugia that they can hide in so dust
can exacerbate problems there are also
native and introduced bio control
methods that are available this is just
some of the commercially available
predatory mites phyto seals / similars
Neela's californica scale and Roma's
accident tell us in addition to many
other predatory mites that are available
some of these may already occur in
regions or they can be purchased and
augmented if they're already there see
if they're doing the job for you and
finally use mite specific tools to
control them so use my decides to treat
populations rather than using
broad-spectrum insecticides moving on to
thrips we've been looking at thrips in
my lab and blackberries for two years
now and we're going we're getting ready
to roll into a third year and the reason
why we're looking at them is because
there's been grower concern about fruit
injury and potential pollination impacts
they're also a potential contamination
pest this is a box of blackberries that
I bought at the grocery store this
summer and I'm not going to say where
they were from as I was sitting driving
in my car the way home I noticed that
thrips were crawling out of the box so I
had to make my significant other take a
detour to the lab so I could take a
picture of the thrips that were coming
out of these blackberries that I just
purchased at the gross grocery store so
they are a potential contamination pest
the objectives of this research were to
figure out because we essentially knew
nothing about the thrips that were here
the diversity and the seasonal biology
of what was present and if they were
actually causing a problem if so what
management strategies could we use so
what we found is that thrips are present
in both flowers and foliage
in much higher numbers in the in the
flowers however and the plant samples
peak during bloom you can see in the
dark orange line and the open square
line here
those are alarm thrips and our adult
thrips in samples those samples peak off
the plant in bloom however our trap
captures continue to increase even
though our plant samples decrease so our
trap captures although pretty decent at
tracking our plant samples early in the
season just keep going up because they
continue to move around but they're not
present on the plants in the same way
the traps that we're using are these two
commercially available traps this is a
yellow AM trap and a blue card trap both
of these are available from Great Lakes
IPM and Laura gave you the link earlier
in the chat and these are some homemade
traps that we use because they allow us
to identify two species the thrips that
we're catching on them so they're the
same color as the two other traps that
we're using but we use them because
they're a little a nicer research tool
but commercially these are the types of
traps that would be out there and I'll
go back to that slide first I could just
illustrate that numerically we tend to
catch more thrips in the blue traps but
the results between the two years have
been a little conflicting we got
significantly more thrips in our blue
traps in 2008 and in 2009 we didn't see
significant differences except for one
date between our blue traps and our
yellow traps the reason why we use
different colors is because different
species of thrips are attracted to
different colors so we wanted to make
sure that we were catching what was out
there as I mentioned our blossom samples
have a much higher density our foliage
samples have some thrips out there but
they have a much higher diversity and
that's just illustrated by these two
figures our blossom sample over here and
our foliage sample over here lots of
different species showing up here really
only one species here which are Eastern
flower throats we've been looking at
insecticide efficacy for these for this
particular group of insects as well and
I'll just give you the Cliff Notes
version of that we can reduce strips
numbers with
sides but this reduction hasn't
correspondent with an increase in fruit
size and increase in drupelet number or
an increase in better shaped fruit and
I'll show you some some data on that
fruit set was not assessed assessed in
these trials but we did a small-scale
caging trial in 2009 to see if we could
force damage from these insects and
blackberries
this was done in Kinston North Carolina
we cashed
buds or flowers either mature buds that
were going to be flowers in a matter of
a day or so or open flowers with
different densities of thrips with 0 5
10 and 20 thrips and then we assessed
fruit set size shape driplets white
drupelets because we folks were
concerned that white triplets may also
be related to this there are some
limitations as this trial that I'll be
completely upfront about we didn't look
at survivorship of the thrip so we
didn't go back and make sure they made
it through the week that they were caged
on there
we used Western flour thrips because
that's what we had in the colony and we
also there might have been some
potential effects to caging although I
don't think so however at those
densities we saw no difference in the
number of fruits that were set so this
is 90 percent fruit set and almost all
of our cages we saw no difference in
fruit volume again none of these are
significantly different from each other
and we saw no difference in the number
of drupelets so our take-home message
there is we've been doing a lot of work
with rips but we don't think based on
this evidence and the fact that we see
no correlation in our insecticide trials
between reducing thrips and having
increased fruit quality that we actually
have something that's causing damage to
the fruit so instead we're shifting our
focus to looking at them as potential
virus factors the thrips that are in red
boxes on these two pie charts are known
vectors of viruses that can be found in
blackberries we're also as part of a
greater group that Don is involved in
and one of our attendees here Danny
LaBelle is also involved in we're
looking at other potential virus vectors
in Cambridge
including leaf hoppers whiteflies and
aphids and this is just an illustration
of some of the leaf hoppers that we find
in our traps these are leaf hopper
species called Graff Assefa lover Sudha
that's a known pathogen vector in other
simple and other systems especially
great so just to briefly touch on some
of my other interests here to talk about
some potential cane very pests the first
one I want to briefly mention is the
light brown apple moth this is the
region in California where this
particular invasive pest is currently
located at and is under quarantine for
the light brown apple moth is a leaf
roller and it does pretty much the same
thing as many other native leaf rollers
that we have here these are photos off
of mark bulldoze blog I gave you all the
link in the notes page and I encourage
you to take a look at that mark Valda is
a farm advisor in Santa Cruz County
California one of the areas where they
grow a lot of their their cane berries
and here's some potential damage the
light brown apple moth can cause decay
in berries the actual feeding of the
insect on the leaves is not as much of a
concern but they'll tunnel up and build
these silken cases for themselves and
that can be a contamination issue and
this is what the larva looks like I
don't anticipate that light brown apple
moth is going to be a game changer in
terms of management for us but it is a
quarantine pest and that can raise
issues for export and import from areas
so that's its primary role as as as a
issue in terms of being an invasive pest
but it has yet to have spread widely
beyond California there are active
trapping programs in the southeast and
if this is something you're concerned
about definitely talk with Cooperative
Extension agents in your area the next
insect which may potentially be more
important than light brown apple moth is
the spotted wing Drosophila this is a
male spotted wing Drosophila you can see
right there how it gets its names it has
two spots one on each wing this is a
female spotted wing Drosophila and this
is a close-up of what makes them
interesting in terms of pest management
she has a serrated knife like ovipositor
egg-laying device that she uses to
infest sound fruit this is what makes
this particular fly so different from
other Drosophila species which were
primarily familiar with as being the
little flies that get on our bananas if
we let them get overripe in our house
these guys like sound fruit out in the
field and this is a larva feeding in a
cherry what's particularly troubling
about them is that they've spread
rapidly since their initial detection in
2008 in some backyard cherries in
California up and down the west coast so
they're now found at many locations in
California many locations in Oregon some
spots in Washington and they've been
detected in Florida so that spread
itself has been pretty rapid that being
said they don't like cold weather that
much so I'm really interested to see
what's going to happen after this winter
I anticipate that if we have decent
overwintering populations in California
which we do that that spread is just as
likely to occur again even if the harsh
winter conditions in Florida and on the
East Coast have knocked down those
populations there as I mentioned the
larvae feed on sound soft skin fruit
they're probably not going to be an
issue for citrus production it's just
too thick for them to get through but
for things like cane berries they're
particularly problematic mark bold again
in California has some really nice posts
on this particular insect so if you want
more details on management tools that
they're working out that's an excellent
resource to check out they have a very
short generation time that means they
can have lots and lots of generations in
a ripening cane berry plot
females lay lots of eggs and I mentioned
there's a high mortality at freezing
temperatures so it's possible that this
winter was a little hard on them
particularly on those East Coast
populations which would be encouraging I
have on here that the males are sterile
at greater than 86 degrees Fahrenheit I
don't want that to be too comforting to
folks because folks in the southeast see
that and we think okay well we're not
gonna have to worry about them as much
but there's pretty much somewhere during
the summer where the insects could
and find temperatures that are below 86
degrees even on really hot days so I
don't know if that's necessarily going
to be a game breaker again I mentioned
Mark boldest blog is an excellent
resource for information on this
particular past we're developing an
early detection monitoring network in
the mid-south specifically in North
Carolina South Carolina and Virginia
we're going to be we're going to begin
training people in March and there's a
lot more info on that on my blog finally
I'll just talk a little bit about stink
bugs the stink bug work has been done by
Don's
Doug Pfeiffer and Laura Maxie at a
university attack and there's a number
of different species of stink bugs that
can be present in Cain berries
particularly in the southeast the fruit
damage that they're causing however is
unclear there's no threshold or scouting
procedures for them and only
broad-spectrum insecticides are
registered and therefore recommended
what Laura's been working on is actually
looking at the feeding behavior of stink
bugs and seeing what type of damage they
might actually be causing what she's
observed them doing is feeding on veins
of leaves sepals on developing fruit and
then this is some of the injury
associated with stink bugs she's been
seeing on fruit she's been seeing this
type of injury to individual droplets
and this is actually due to feeding by
the bug between the droplets not on the
individual drupelets themselves and I'll
mention that again as we flip through to
the video at the very end this is the
other type of damage we're concerned
about stinkbugs are potential
contamination nuisance as well as we all
know they're named stink bugs for a
reason and you can actually smell and
taste
when stink bugs release their odorous
compounds on and around cane berries so
there are contamination concern because
of that this is the video I mentioned
this is saved as a file that you can
download in the file sharing section I
encourage all of you to do it do that
what it's what it actually shows is the
stylet of this green stink bug here
going between
the drupelets and feeding so unlike what
we thought just thinking beforehand
before Laura did this work we were
assuming that the sink bugs were
probably feeding on these individual
droplets and potentially causing them to
be leaky causing them to turn white
causing damage to them but that hasn't
been what they've observed what they've
observed is actually feeding between
them that may damage the drupelets
surrounding that feeding puncture
because of damage to the the receptacle
underneath but not necessarily
individual drupelet feeding and I think
that's my last slide so with that I'll
encourage you all to download that file
from from the file sharing section and
I'm sorry we couldn't play it for you
and I'll take any questions that you
have I'm going to move us into that file
sharing so that people can download this
one it's the greens by yellow rasp right
there that's the file that you can
upload and I will also post both PDF of
both the dr. Johnson and dr. Brock's
presentations right now so that you can
get them before the end I do hope that
folks if you've got questions for dr.
Brock or dr. Johnson please now's your
chance
have any questions anybody they're
trying to soak it all in I'm sure that
was a lot of great information and I
also want to comment that it really is
it's really interesting for me as an
extension person to watch in other areas
where some of these pests the different
pest problems because it's been alarming
to me I've worked in extension for 20
years or so and just the change in the
diseases and insects that we see that we
thought we would not see in our area we
are seeing now and this is a nice
opportunity for us to get a little
heads-up about what might be coming our
way
no questions for dr. Barak or dr.
Johnson anybody well I think there I
think we've totally wowed them thank you
guys very much I also want to thank all
of you for joining us for all these
berry webinar series
I really am indebted to my colleagues
Cathy Heidenreich for all of the PR work
she helped me with for all of the
extension host Jeff Miller Colleen
Cavanaugh
Sharon Bachman sook wise for hosting
live sessions and dr. Marvin Pritz for
his guidance on this and I also want to
thank all of our speakers we had some
excellent excellent speakers and I'm
looking forward to having those archives
available to everyone thank you so much
dr. Johnson and dr. Barak and please all
of you registrants be looking for a
survey that will be coming in the next
couple of weeks this is very important
for the our final analysis for the
program and this will help us with
future webinar series and we want all of
your comments constructive criticism and
otherwise please don't hesitate to share
that and thank you all very very much
I will post Don's presentation right now
and again thanks a lot and you all have
my contact info both from my
presentation
and from my webpage and feel free to to
get in touch I put that there for a
reason